new medical research shows that men and
women have different food cravings men
preferring meat and women preferring
sweets scientists trace this back to
caveman days when men had to go out and
hunt for food while women sat on their
fat asses eating chocolates sugar ray is
a great champion sugar we'd ask you to
talk but you know the blacks your lips
lock the vagina is stronger than money
stronger than money
yes about could I put one in my wallet
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then I go to pay for this thing's
gonna be cash or charge
that's how I'll pay with my you know
what they say about an automobile no an
automobile is a man's extension of his
of his virility in other words the macho
image at it's a sense of yeah but I feel
the macho man I'm feeling young I mean
I'm not gonna make love eight nine times
a night
[Applause]
I know I can't I just need a woman you
know when I have a lovely Jewish wife in
fact she's a monk she was supposed to
come with me today but she couldn't get
off the bed the jewelry was too heavy
well according to a new entertainment
weekly poll 72% of their readers say
they would not be offended if a TV show
lead character were gay though that
figure shrinks to 1% when these same
readers are reminded that being gay can
involve anal sex
you'd like to be the first black
president yes and nobody will kill me
Conan a lot of black people are afraid
of assassination you don't come on pal
I'm not worried about those kinds of
things because my vice-president will be
Mexican oh man I can't lay on the beach
my lady can lay on the beach and just
close her eyes and I'm always afraid
somebody's gonna tip up on you and bust
your handle Bob Hope as you all know
he's in the back standing there with
three soldiers an American flag saying
find another war
yeah Ricki Lake you know she is really
is an animal lover though she has three
cats two dogs and a big ass that follows
her around everywhere
the apron sitting at dinner yeah I'm not
even making something was eating
watermelon I was like oh the movie they
run from the Apes and they run the water
cuz the Apes can't swim at the end is
like when I seen the ape smoking a new
port I just got up recently I just have
nightmares I'd be sleep and people would
take me in another room and operate on
my brain put me back in the other room
when I wake up and one night in New York
I went to sleep and I had the dream and
I woke up and went to the door and a
nurse was leaving the other partner what
age were you when you had your first
homosexual experience
there's 11 he was a tall cowboy from
town
it started out it came in the room and
went last week on Larry King Live Marlon
Brando made the shocking statement that
Hollywood is quote run by Jews in
response outraged Jewish organizations
made it snow in New York in April I saw
your baby very nice babies how old's the
baby now he got he's 18 months now
that's very cool I can't quite talk here
but that's what I'm waiting for
yeah yeah phone to talk yeah cuz
whenever you ever had a conversation
with a guy that lived in your balls you
know my wife my ex-wife went to court
she looked like a 12 year old girl I
didn't even know she was she walked in
joy I started crying just looking at her
because I knew I was going to
penitentiary or something
this wonderful black man say in my
kitchen we know each other a lot of
years really and I love the black people
we need your people I swear because no
Jews gonna make up a train
[Music]
in New Zealand a convicted swindler who
weighs 670 pounds has been sentenced to
house arrest because he is too big for
prison according to prison officials it
took four inmates just to rape him a lot
of people now feel like Oh Clinton lied
to us did you feel like you know the
president lied to you or well that's why
I like him because yes he did lied to us
we let it good was there is that we knew
he was last but what made it a
masterpiece is that he knew that we knew
that he was laughing hey would you do me
a favor
yeah sit up when I look at you I think
we're on a Titanic
a down-and-out oj simpson does press
that all of his money-making ideas have
failed has decided to go back to doing
what he does best killing people i want
on the page it's so good to see you they
have you on most of the rows because
somebody has to dust the table
because other people don't admit that
deep down inside if I may be serious for
a moment that you do something on the
stage that all of us would like to do if
we had no class
and finally Weekend Update would like to
congratulate Madonna who gave birth to a
beautiful baby girl last Monday the baby
weighed in at 6 pounds 9 ounces making
it the fourth largest object ever to
pass through Madonna's birth canal I
think my first my first performance was
like my uncle my uncle deke brought me
up bought me a cowboy suit right with
two guns and stuff and I was in the
front yard you know and all the family
was sitting on the porch animus and dog
poo poo in the yard and I slipped and
fell in it big stream and I started
laughing so I got up and felt it again
this whole front row here I I am what I
am the man on the end take a look at
that man oh I don't know who you are but
you're a bad-looking man look at that
the lady when he knows you but I went
through the American Academy of Dramatic
Arts which they keep it quiet you know
Robert Redford's Jason Robards was on
scholarship no no no no I just walked in
it's not an actor ah you don't get a
scholarship you pay the audition don't
be a dumbbell I hate it read the paper
know the questions I mean what does this
stump the stars Darren McGavin you're
the night stalkers my favorite show in
fact I use that when your show is a
night light when I fool with the wife
now have you had any trouble with that
you have a ninety trouble the police
have you you don't get it you know no
not at all
but I have a police scanner you it looks
like a Walkman people think I'm
listening to music but I'm getting
important information
she just walking down the street
listening to a police scanner yeah you
might hear something calling all cars
calling all cars be on the lookout for a
black male between four seven and six
eight
[Music]
I'd better get off the streets for a
minute here wonderful wonderful new wife
Barbara
[Applause]
the Jewish wife she doesn't do that she
has so much jewelry on she can't keep
her head up
[Applause]
I just drove it
[Applause]